Nikki Haley appeared on Neil cavuto's
Fox News show yesterday
she tried to explain her plan to raise
the social security retirement age and
it ended up being an insane word salad
that made no sense she really is
struggling to explain her policies let's
take a listen Governor then how would
you dress when you talked about changing
the retirement age security what were
you talking about
so if we're talking about entitlement
reform the first thing we do is look I
have parents in my eight in their 80s we
take care of them I don't want anything
to hurt the seniors or anyone that's
getting ready to retire but I have kids
in in their 20s those are the ones that
need to go and know that things are
going to be changed so what you would do
is for those in their 20s coming into
the system we would change the
retirement age so that it matches life
expectancy the second thing we would do
is we would limit benefits for the
wealthy that then you go further instead
of Now understand that benefits are
already limited for the wealthy and it
has nothing to do with inflation like
this is just a mishmash that reflects a
total lack of understanding and lack of
thinking about what the hell is going on
living in crisis do increases based on
inflation that's something Republicans
and Democrats would agree with and then
more than that expand Medicare Advantage
plans so that we have more competition
and we run the cost down now that
actually has nothing to do with Social
Security nothing that's what entitlement
form will look like that's how you're
going to make it sustainable and that's
also how you bring down the cost of what
we're seeing right now so when you're
talking about adjusting the ages
depending on you know looking kids in
their 20s and obviously uh that they can
come into the program later and they
might have other options
um what are you telling those in their
60s now or in their 50s now at what
point would a a president Nikki Haley uh
say all right we're we're bringing you
in a little later
you keep your promises to those that
were that we've made promises to those
that have invested in should keep what
they have we shouldn't in any way
jeopardize those that are already
expecting something yeah but the problem
is when she talks about people in their
20s will get lower benefits most people
in their 20s have also started to pay in
so really if you wanted to do this
fairly you would say
we're going to raise the retirement age
for people who have not yet started to
pay in that would really be the quote
Fair way to do it under this Paradigm
it's about the new group coming in I'm
sorry
I'm sorry what's the new group is it are
you telling those 50 and over you're
safe the 50 and under you're on I I just
use that arbitrary number what are you
saying is a group that what you're
saying that's going to change
it's the new ones coming in it's those
in their 20s that are coming in but
remember
people in their 20s particularly if they
had jobs in high school or during
college they've already started paying
in with the belief that their benefits
are going to be based on the current
system so it doesn't really work you're
coming to them and you're saying the
game has changed we're going to do this
completely differently that's how you go
and you focus on it we've got to start
doing things like that but more than
that I mean we have to look at the fact
that there is a spending problem in DC
okay and that's totally unrelated
because that's actually a separate issue
from the way that Social Security is
funded and they they love to do that
they go well we've got debt okay right
but like the social security system has
its own tax collection system and its
own benefit system and the funds are
invested in a particular way what does
our general debt have to do with it it
really doesn't have much to do with it
unless they wanted to argue well
inflation in General devalues Social
Security benefits but they're index to
inflation at least in theory so Nikki
Haley is not exactly showing a deep
understanding of this she's talking
about limiting benefits for wealthy
people their benefits are already
limited then and in part they're limited
by the fact that we only tax the first
hundred and whatever thousand of income
and that is where the limitation comes
from and then she's talking about
Medicare Advantage and whatever else I
don't think she really understands
what's going on that's my opinion based
on this response
you let me know if you disagree